What's up my fellow bros?
That's right
(laughs)
That's right, I am inside videogame.
Look at this
AHHHHHH
Mom someone put me in the videogame.
Now, let's freakin do this
We're gonna play Beat Saber. Oh, look at that, huh?
You're not so tough now, are you?
We're gonna play Beat Saber
It's a game where you have lightsabers and hit to the tone of the beats. I sure hope none of this is copyrighted
because I would have wasted all the hours that I spent setting this up. For some goddamn reason
I thought this was a good idea. Let's freakin do this. I had no time to actually play this goddamn game
Beat Saber
So this is my perspective. This is how it looks for me. Pretty cool. Let's stop...
did I forget to put on my headphones?
I...found them, found them
No problem.
Okay, that's better I'm legit so excited to actually play it. Commercial pumping. I can do some fun things
Okay, let's freakin do it. Look at this guys
My saber, where is it?
I'm missing it...
What the Frank?
Let's freakin do...Look at it. This is my perspective look at it
So you're supposed to cut...you've probably seen everyone play this game, right?
I don't know why I'm explaining it. Okay
I don't know why whenever I play this. Ah
I feel so sassy
Doctor but I lost weight. I'm weighing them the wrong way. I was wearing them guys. It's not fair. I didn't realize I usually
Stop. Yeah, I do not fail normal Ligety. Oh
Hey
I just realize I put on the perfect shirt today. Stop dammit
Ah
You feel that, that's right
Whoa
God damn
Do I look as cool as I feel like this goddamn it? I feel cool
Did you say that
Okay, all right you get the gist that's the song is kind of annoying you're still watching huh, there it is I downloaded
none other
Will it be because I knew everything would get copyrighted. So why not just play my own side
Nothing. Nothing pursue did but I must go all out. Oh, yeah, just it just this once
To do that
Okay, okay, okay wait I'll do I'll do no fail on that one just for the meme come on I don't like your t-series
I don't like your taste a race. Nothing personal kid
But I must go all-out
That's right. Just just this once come up
He's beginning to blame
Because
It is
So satisfied
Who the hell is
God damn
God damn. Oh
Oh
My god, let's play something else
How about this?
Nintendo GameCube
Ok, that should be easy. Alright, let's do this
What the hell was that wait again that's impossible
What
Ok, I'm not easy
What the Frick
This is so satisfying, I love it. I know I'm not saying anything. I'm just so focused I
Don't know what to say. I wish I was killing
Slicing up Mario
Damn I'm terrible is it what else? Did we get the greatest enemy of all time lucky star
Cool
Wow
This is so
thing I've ever done but I
But megalovania
That's epic Oh God. Oh
My god
No one has ever done this
I'm already exhausted. Please make it stop
Why am I wearing a sweater god dammit my mic exercising is oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I have the greatest
just need a
Okay, whoa
the halo thing
Ooh, ah
Who
Oh, yeah
Come on Berenice ha you track me
This is amazing, this one is great
Oh, yeah
Oh
My god that was amazing that was actually cream worthy it's time for the most important song of all time
This is insane
Hey, Monica Calabria, July cool. I can't see anything
Tommy hon. I'll be sunny back and you don't you team?
I'm loosing the grip up there patrollers
Hey, hey hey
Wow Oh
I hope you enjoyed it allows this video
here one more
Don't worry. It's never happen again
Setting this up smash like if you want more of this and I see your brows and the next episode
Oh
Do I look insane cuz I feel insane Jesus Christ man, I guess I don't need to work out today